I'm not kidding I know I could quote so
many Frasier episodes to right now I'm
so whenever I found out they were
rebooting it I freaked out did yes I'm
not kidding there are C the level of wit
the comedic timing the physical comedy
like all of it it's all there and I
think it's one of those I'm not not to
dog any shows now I just think there
aren't really shows like that now so I'm
so excited like why did you want to
reboot it now thanks well it was just it
seemed like the right time to do it yeah
um six years ago um the Rosano kind of
came back and then it was a big big hit
and I thought well you know Frasier
hasn't gone anywhere he's just sort of
drifted off into the you know he is a
part of our family yes I love him and uh
it it seemed like a good idea to bring
him back because he was always funny and
he had had a nice Take On The World and
he loved the world and he wanted to make
things better so it seemed like it was a
good time to to step back into the role
yeah did you always cuz your voice I
mean just one of the greatest voices
speaking voice see it's just a great
thank you you that's a big compliment
well it's it's a gorgeous tone that
people like dream of and did you always
did you always think you were going to
do the theme song to frer was there ever
any other idea well what I did was I
said to them uh the producers at the
time I said oh by the way I am going to
sing the theme song is that what you did
and they said uh well we're not planning
on making a theme song I said well maybe
we should plan on making one I love it I
love it you're just like no no I have so
he ended up with this sort of weird
hybrid song it doesn't have like a
middle verse or anything like that it
doesn't have like a whole story to tell
but it is that sort of Jazzy sting thing
which seemed really appropriate and it
uh it has become very popular soate for
Fraser crane like it's just it fits so
perfectly and it's in everyone's heads
forever I love it so much um thank you
for singing it with me I was very
excited my honor I was and I just love
that jazz Vibe like that whole setup is
so we changed it a little bit for this
this incarnation of the show because I
thought well he's a little wiser he's a
little more mellow he's a little more
comfortable in his own skin yeah and so
we should like uh lower it and kind of
you know ease into a little bit more I
love that so that was purposeful the new
arrangement for new yeah I love that did
you I hear that you always have you must
love singing you always have karaoke at
your parties well I didn't used to have
karaoke at my parties until I met my
wife she so she's better she the karaoke
genius she a genius at it it's amazing
what's a go-to song for either one of
you uh well she she sings Karen
Carpenter like like Karen Carpenter
couldn't I mean it's amazing it's clear
as B yeah she's here she's up there oh
my gosh I love Karen Carpenter it's
amazing yeah when when she sings those
songs I can take all set The Madness of
the world has to give oh my God it's
just it's extraordinary it's so clear
and she also sings Desperado like no
one's ever s i just sing Desperado here
ma'am it's about the sexiest thing
you've ever heard in your life when she
says you know open the gate it's like
yeah bab like fine I will I love it
coming on in wait what's your go to uh I
I tend to sing uh I'll do Let's Dance by
David Boe and uh we have another
distinction that I share with David Boe
which is very interesting I I had a
little heart trouble about uh 15 years
ago yeah and what the nurses told me was
said oh David Bowie was in his bed
before
you you're like I'm gonna make it
finally finally have arrived that's
amazing and then and the guy and before
him was Paul Newman like are you serious
they're probably not supposed to tell
you but that particular does this person
only work on super famous people I it
was that it was that room apparently so
oh my gosh back to Fraser back to FR um
because I'm very excited so back in
Boston yes so this was all purposeful
this is like full circle I wanted to I
wanted to bring the whole legacy cast
back but in a different world you know
we all moved on to something else but we
would still be connected uh that didn't
work out okay so once that happened
after about 3 years of really trying to
kind of sell that idea to everybody uh I
went home and thought well what do we do
now and I actually in a dream I said oh
he's got to go back to Boston he hasn't
finished he didn't he didn't leave
Boston the right way yeah the original
concept was that he had to get all the
way across the country because we just
wanted to get away from Boston to start
the new show yeah but that was just a
kind of a geographical happen stance I
thought in this one he he left the thing
with Diane didn't work out Lilian he got
divorced his son has been in Boston ever
since I thought he's got stuff he's got
to do in Boston still and because so
when when he went there as a young man
to first go to Harvard it didn't work
out the way he wanted it to so he had
some stuff to deal with yeah yeah so
we're back so relatable yeah I love that
there is a tribute to John Mahoney who
played your father is that the name of
the bar Mahoney's bar yeah the baby's
name is John um um the daany daany and
Niles is oh I loved him um and Eddie oh
man I love yeah you have no idea I have
but yeah he you know John John T A few
years back and um I just thought well we
can't do the show again without honoring
John we just can't you know and and it
has to it has to begin with the fact
that John is gone and Dad's Gone
Martin's gone and so that then I become
dad you know oh my gosh okay my makeup
artist will kill me I'm a I'm a
contagious
crier I'm going to be fine just yeah
okay um in in Boston though um you're
back there so do you think any cheers
like characters will come in and out no
I mean look don't let me down cheers
people I was like that would be amazing
just one the the bar the bar is closed
we you know I mean Jimmy's decided that
know the bar went out of business for
whatever reason but I would like to see
Diane come back yeah just for one of
those reasons of of you know Fraser
being able to put something to bed to
end up with a nice thing between them
yeah and and uh and to kind of just
ReDiscover how much cuz when I first got
the role the key to Fraser for me was
was that he loved her with his whole
heart that he loved with all of his
being and he's and that actually defined
who he is he's been that way ever since
he just goes in wholeheartedly with
everything and that's what makes him
funny yeah oh so witty oh my gosh God
I'm just so excited this show is back on
the level of wit is H and the El elitism
is just so funny still there oh my God I
love it's still there um I have to say
this too speaking of your wife we were
talking about earlier y'all you're
celebrating your anniversary soon right
February 25th yeah and you were married
in New York City we were married on the
stage of the Longacre theater where I
was performing um L Kaja fall what which
Kate and I met when I rehearsed that
actually and uh oh that's magic we fell
in love it's the shows about love we
fell in love it just was a perfect
combination and we uh we had a what a
mve we had the ceremony on the stage and
then we uh had our reception at the
plaza and people still talk about that
it was oh man our reception let's talk
yeah that's one to talk about yeah
weddings I'm always like me the
receptions that's where the people come
out you know like little liquid courage
and you see who really wanted to be a
dancer you know like it's amazing they
were all dancers at are I know that's
what I'm saying it's a like oh yeah I
was totally going to be a Daner W was
like I love wedding reception so much
yeah but um so wait so your kids they
range from 7 to 40 yes so that's do you
feel it I know
hey I got I got a I got a hey when you
were first when you were first
introducing this lovely young woman up
here I thought you were going to
actually say we have a big surprise for
you Kelsey because one of the children
you don't know
about I know it's a recurring nightmare
for my wife oh my God this amazing you
are so funny wait but I do have a
question because I feel like I had kids
later in life than a lot of my friends
like and I feel like I think I'm better
for it starting later in life do you
think that you're a different dad from
the younger batch the older batch yeah I
mean yeah I mean you know I I had more
stuff to figure out when I was younger I
mean I still had the still had the war
to fight you know I still had the the
the battle to become who I am that
that's a that takes up a lot of time and
so sometimes having kids is wonderful
you think it's a good thing you do your
best but you miss some things and I
missed some things with my older kids
there's no question the the beauty is
that you know God and life has given me
a chance to make up for it yeah you know
to kind of try to patch it all up and
make it good so I'm doing my best to do
that faith is a big thing for you right
a very big thing yeah yeah I think
that's very important well I chased
Faith all my life when I was little you
know I I I I went to Sunday school to
Christian Science school and uh whenever
the woman would say would you like who
would like to read this passage from the
Bible I thought I'd like to read it and
I think that
actually taught me my love of language I
think my my love of the word right of
the English language came from reading
the Bible yeah and so I would walk kind
of hand inand with the idea of God's
word and God and Jesus and stuff and
then of course I had you know some very
difficult things happened in my life and
M you know I went through the classic
you know I cursed God and said no thanks
I don't need your help I'd rather just
handle this alone if this is the way
it's going to be and then what's
interesting is you know it never
occurred to me to say uh oh what what
what are you up to meaning the enemy you
know it's like nobody ever says to God
get in there oh you know so so the other
guy I don't I don't appreciate what
you've done here yeah uh we always go
God why did you let this happen well
maybe he didn't let it happen yeah maybe
it's a not today somebody else came and
got yeah right exactly what I say not
today sir you will not get this girl's
Joy so I carry I carry that with me a
lot and uh eventually I just kind of got
back on track and and met you know REM
met Jesus I guess you could say and I
carry him with me and it's been a great
thing that's very beautiful and that
kind of testimony is so powerful too to
tell everybody that's cool so I I have
to say this you this is I mean you're
from cheers originally and now you own a
brewery and I think that's amazing you
own a brewery Upstate right yeah I love
Upstate New York do you love it I
absolutely adore it yeah yeah a faith
American Brewing Company that's that's
what I what was your why did you want to
do that uh the water it's uh it's I've
had this property up there uh for 26
years yeah and uh I'd walk the trails
and hike and stuff and see the water and
think gosh we got to do something with
this it used to be a really really you
know successful Place prosperous place
there was a dairy farm and a a big
cauliflower Farm the largest cauliflower
Farm on the East Coast for years wow and
uh it the old old folks to come from
that town say oh yeah I used to pack
cauliflower pits up there at uh you know
your old place and they go yeah okay
they also used they ALS used to trap
black minks so you know obviously that's
a different story too yeah u in any case
um the beer seems like the natural thing
and my wife actually suggested the beer
as well and we go through a big battle
about that she got great ideas yeah she
karaoke alcohol you did the beer because
you know because I said so and I said I
know I never thought of it
before I like her already um we have a
game next do you want to play a game
yeah I heard this game we're going to
play okay well I'm just saying it's good
that you have faith in God In Prayer
because you're going to need it well we
yes I'm competitive um well we sang The
Frasier theme song earlier and up next
we've got a game about some of the best
TV show theme songs of all time which I
love be sure to watch Frasier on
Paramount plus everybody we'll be right
[Music]
back
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home